this video is sponsored by
Squarespace hello and welcome to the
closest thing you're going to get on
this channel to a Halloween special
we're talking about when Fitness turns
bad sorry if that was a bit too scary
obviously I'm having a little bit of fun
with it because I'm a fun guy but this
is also a serious topic or a bunch of
serious topics because I think everybody
starts out with Fitness with the
intention of getting healthier at least
ostensibly but very often something goes
wrong along the way Fitness can start
off great but become a little bit
destructive or dare I say it toxic and
you only have to look around YouTube to
see how prevalent this has become the
good news is I think more and more
people on YouTube are also talking about
this stuff but I think it's really
important that we do keep talking about
it that we address it and we draw
attention to it and so that's my aim
with this video is to discuss all of the
most common ways that Fitness can
actually become
destructive so let's start with
something that is pretty prevent right
now and that's impossible body standards
a lot of people start out with Fitness
because they want to look like their
idols and there's nothing wrong with
that it's great to have you know role
models and inspiration the problem is
when the people you're looking up to
offer impossible standards impossible
because Fitness is their job guilty and
they train all the time little less
guilty impossible because they use
Photoshop and other kinds of editing
impossible because they might be on gear
or steroids or impossible because they
just have fantastic genetics and of of
course what we have to remember is that
Instagram and the internet in general
has a selection bias it's going to show
you the greatest physiques the best
performance and so that's what we
compare ourselves to and it's
unrealistic for a lot of people this can
of course be demotivating it can lead us
to take stupid decisions and it can lead
us to feel bad about ourselves which
obviously we shouldn't it's important to
remember that these are exceptional
physiques you know the 1% or even fewer
and that they have a little bit of help
in most cases and if you saw them cold
in the the street you might not think
all that much about them what I think is
really good is when you see people on
YouTube and Instagram doing that Noble
thing of taking the top off and showing
what they look like cold and without
good lighting and without editing just
to show that a lot of it is a bit of an
illusion I haven't done it myself
because I don't think that many people
are desperate for my physique got more
of a performance focused channel that is
one reason I like to show my outakes and
very often you guys will see me do a
cool move it actually took me like 10
attempts to do that
move
that said some people do say they like
my physique so I thought I'd have a go
with that as well so let's
go boom that's why I look like cold
without any pump haven't done a workout
I've still got overhead lighting so I've
got that going for me but unfortunately
there's nothing I can do about that
unless we do this in the dark so yeah
this is what I look like the rest of the
time I'm actually also not looking my
best at the moment because I've been
sick I injured my elbow so that's the
other thing even if a content creator
does look pretty good all of the time
they might not always look like that and
in fact the better their physique the
harder it is to maintain it year round
but even I definitely have periods where
I'm looking and feeling good then
periods where I kind of Trail off and
it's not so good again nothing to be
ashamed of that's just normal life
normally when you see me working out I'm
crawling through the mud which means I'm
like mid movement which makes me look
better and I've got a pump on because
I've been training outdoor lighting is
actually really good then I do adjust
the contrast I make the Shadows deeper I
increase the sharpness to make image
more pleasing because I enjoy that
aspect of videography and editing but it
is also to make the muscles pop more
because I think that looks better this
is what I look like with a bit of color
grading and a bit of editing and then
this is what I look like without the
color grading and editing I shootting a
flat color profile so it sucks all the
color out of everything and I couldn't
use this anyways but yeah this is what I
look like with no additional help here's
like a normal kind of color grade here's
me blue I actually don't know what this
is going to look like and I'm interested
in watching it back wouldn't it be awful
if I still looked
incredible
and at the same time it's not that deep
if you don't get the perfect body if you
don't look incredible it really doesn't
matter it's not going to change your
life a great deal I've always been
pretty strong but it hasn't made me any
more successful with women it has helped
my career if I'm honest but you know
this is a pretty Niche case getting into
Super shape isn't the answer to all your
problems I think a lot of people make
that mistake of thinking that it is and
therefore they play so much importance
on it that it becomes their whole
identity and they become crushed when
things don't turn out the way they hope
in terms of attracting members of the
opposite sex as a grown-up a Bonafide
adult with kids and a wife of many years
I also have a lot of friends who are in
Long relationships or have kids and
wives and none of them look like
adonises none of them are extremely
bulky or ripped none of them are
successful in the ways that these
YouTube channels tell you you need to be
in order to attract members of the
opposite sex it sounds like a cliche but
genuinely it's true if you just be
yourself and be a nice person a decent
person then there's going to be someone
out there for you and you just need to
find that person tastes vary and
circumstances vary and I mean yeah just
find someone who's your friend who you
can have a bit of banter with who's
normal and you really wouldn't want
someone who only wanted you for your
money and your looks anyways right of
course it's normal to fixate on aspects
of your physicality I for a long time
thought I had a big nose I even spent a
day at work once doing this to try and
make my nose look thinner because I
thought this was a better look so I do
get it but that was stupid clearly I
think we can all agree and likewise
focusing too much on your physique to
the point that you're obsessing about it
and comparing yourself to you know
possible standards is also misguided the
same also goes for performance though
it's not just about looks I think some
people see these incredible lifts on
YouTube and Instagram people benching
two times their body weight people
benching more than that squatting more
than that and they think they need to be
able to do this as well they think it's
normal I think a lot of people get a
sense of belonging from being a
powerlifter being a calisthenics athlete
being whatever else and they think they
need to look and perform like those
people to be a part of that group if you
can bench press anything decent you're
already stronger than the majority of
the population it's not going to again
improve your life in any meaningful way
and being part of an online community
that's that's nothing like make real
friends and does it really matter if you
gain the respect of some random people
on the internet it does not so I'm not
saying don't go after these goals
they're great goals and they have lots
of positive outcomes but focus on the
journey don't get too worked up about
the outcome and don't worry too much if
you don't get there all that quickly
certainly do not take dangerous
shortcuts or perform go lifts or lift
more than you can because what's far
more important is that you look after
your long-term Health all round
performance so that when you start
getting older you can still perform and
enjoy your body to me anyways that is
far more important than being able to
achieve some arbitrary
goal speaking of taking shortcuts
dangerous shortcuts the obvious elephant
in the room in a video like this is
steroids turning to steroids is of
course a way that Fitness can become
damaging to your health again this is
going to come from a feeling of
inadequacy a desire to get better
results faster or in some cases it might
even be incentivized by social media I'd
certainly get more clicks and more money
if I had a more ripped and bulky
physique steroids would get me there but
it would be a big mistake and we're
starting to hear more and more cases of
prominent figures online and in
bodybuilding having serious health
complaints as a result of their steroid
use even dying young in some cases which
is tragic as you guys know I'm into my
technology as well as programming I like
to buy weird gadgets and Tinker with
them and sometimes I might get a bit
Reckless like I don't read properly how
I'm supposed to do it or I install
something that's in a beta form and I
have bricked devices as a result and
it's a crushing feeling knowing that
something you did that was a bit silly
now resulted in you losing this device
that in some cases cost hundreds of
pounds it's depressing it's depressing
because there's no doovers now imagine
doing that to your body imagine messing
with it because you want to get
somewhere faster but then you break it
you break your body you mess up your
hormones to a point that you can't get
them back you get teral acne you lose
your hair your balls shrivel you get
gynocomastia imagine imag that you take
steroids something that's entirely
within your control and you ruin your
body forever and there's no doovers
imagine how that would feel even with
the most precautious approach in the
world even with the most research in the
world we've seen it happen to
professional bodybuilders so it can
certainly happen to you at the same time
you're buying stuff online from elicit
sources that have no regulation even if
you know the stuff you want to buy
you're going to buy something from some
random person who probably isn't the
most upstanding individual in the world
and then inject it into your body with a
syringe there's just so many things that
can go wrong here you might not even be
injecting the stuff you think you are
it's just a bad bad idea and it's a
one-way road now most of you guys
watching this don't need me to tell you
this I'm preaching to the choir but it's
just a tragedy that what's supposed to
be this healthy wholesome activity that
makes us stronger and healthier actually
leads to this really really dangerous
behavior that can kill you and extremely
young people are doing this which is
just even more shocking and terrible
another way that someone desperate to
get into shape might try and take a
shortcut or do something silly is by
spending an awful lot of money and this
is something that I just think is
Insidious I mean there are plenty of
companies and individuals out there
selling supplements that don't do what
they say they're going to do and that
aren't worth the money we see this all
the time every new fad but this one's
different this one actually works until
we find out that it doesn't and we all
wasted our money worse some of these are
actually bad for you so make sure you do
your research and generally just stick
to the basics protein powder and
creatine and if you are interested in
experimenting with some other stuff then
just know what you're getting into and
don't spend a ton of money what I
actually find even more depressing are
these online programs that charge
hundreds or even thousands of dollars I
just don't see any possible excuse for
charging $11,000 for any kind of online
course now I sell an online course I
sell my super functional training
program 2.0 and I think it provides
value I mean it comes with 2 hours of
instructional video and an ebook that's
80 plus pages I think it's a slightly
unique approach to Fitness and it
provides a lot of information I hope
that when I'm selling it I don't promise
things that are impossible and of course
you can get most of the information free
anywhere online I just have done a lot
of research and put it all in one place
if you don't have the the money then I
encourage you not to buy it point is
though I sell it for $ 20 to $50
sometimes it goes Less in a sale and I
never go beyond that I personally also
buy training programs I think they can
be useful point is I personally don't
think there's anything wrong with
selling a training program like this
after all it's how I make my money
YouTubers do need to be paid as well and
other sources such as AdSense aren't
that reliable but with that said I don't
see any way that a training program
could possibly be worth £1,000 because
it costs nothing to print and don't buy
programs thinking it's going to get you
into training start training regularly
and once you've found the ability to
commit to training then start to expand
your knowledge by potentially investing
in an affordable program that will just
give you some more ideas to try and then
adapt it and see how it fits in with
your
routine ultimately many of these issues
can be likened to the rise of hustle
culture online hustle culture being this
glamorization of working insane hours of
pushing yourself hard working in all
your spare time and neglecting other
aspects of your life maybe even other
aspects of your health when you apply
that same mentality do training it can
be even more dangerous because we're now
ignoring things like you know the
limitations of our body and overtraining
when you constantly think that you need
to push harder and that anything else is
a sign of weakness this can only lead to
eventually self-destruction but we still
haven't even touched on some of the most
dangerous aspects of Fitness so I'm
going to save that for next time and
we're going to talk about some things
that are maybe a little bit
controversial and that are also highly
Insidious one aspect in particular that
kind of ties all this stuff together
that maybe isn't responsible as such
because these issues have existed
forever but which has triggered the rise
of this approach online and is making
Fitness more more dangerous and harmful
to more and more people so I'll see you
next time and until then bye for
now building a website can be a
fantastic tool to propel yourself or
your business online but it can also
just be an excellent form of
self-expression and that's why I love
today's sponsor
Squarespace Squarespace makes it
extremely easy for anyone to build a
website taking away any need for code or
complex tools you simply choose a
template you like the looks of and then
edit it and customize it by dragging and
dropping elements any way you want on
the page you can literally have a
website up and running in minutes and
I'm not exaggerating meaning that anyone
can start putting stuff out there for
the world to see but while Squarespace
makes it very easy for beginners to get
started it also comes with all of the
tools and advanced features you could
possibly need to grow your business to
any Heights online that means things
like Advanced publishing tools allowing
you to create beautiful looking blog
posts and schedule them to post when you
need them to it has a fully integrated
commenting system making it very easy to
build a Community member management
analytics gated members only content for
Revenue Generation all that good stuff
and if you want to take it further you
can call on the huge selection of
plugins provided by the community and by
Squarespace themselves in order to add
features that you might need e-commerce
is built into Squarespace for example
but then you can add things like global
Shipping and inventory management tax
reconciliation tools really anything you
could possibly need if you want to learn
more about Squarespace then head over to
squarespace.com and when you're ready to
launch head over to squarespace.com
bioner for 10% off of your first domain
or website thanks again to you guys for
watching and thank you to Squarespace
for
sponsoring bye for
now